so directing accolades four days but I'm
wondering first feature film here is
there anything about telling a story in
this format that really surprised you I
think everything in a way was completely
unexpected it was a marathon you know
I'm used to a sprint I'm used to quick
what I call a quick high where I get to
create and some things out in the world
and you know a week or so and to work on
something for two years of my life to
actually be in pre-pro to pose for a
whole year and to have that sacrifice
that it takes as a director was was it's
a new world so you know very exciting
worlds what do you like to have in your
hands when you go to set as a director
and does that change on a feature film
versus music videos and TV it definitely
changes from videos the TV and film cuz
there's just more narrative but when I
go to said I just have a shot list for
the day i over li prepare myself but in
a way where I can also throw it out and
just be open to seeing and creating on
set because you go in with a plan but
sometimes there's something greater
waiting to happen and you have to be
open to that as well so I show up with
that with some tea in the morning
because it's gotta wake up it's usually
early and with a strong approach to how
I want to you know talk to the actors
and inform their performances that day
and have a vision of what I want to see
right there and you know you're working
within the constraints of a feature film
budget here so with that in mind is
there anything in particular that you
wanted to do whether it's a story beat
or some sort of visual technique that
you kind of had to fight for you how to
push to make it happen yeah I think
that's what every projects right you
never have enough regardless of you know
what your budget is or so I've heard but
I really wanted to fight to shoot on
film that was really one of the
prerequisites of how I wanted to go in
so the approach to this I feel like my
most successful work has been shot on
film and I knew it would have a soul
that I couldn't
bring with a digital kind of approach to
it so that was necessary and then I also
wanted to travel I wanted it to be a
real world journey I wanted them to go
from the north to the south and travel
through at least three states and not be
on the sounds there's you know created
like rear projection or using LED
screens to have these really intimate
moments I wanted the moving landscapes
and the moving pavement below them to
really inform their performances as
actors and also become another character
in the film I also wanted to ask you
specifically about crafting the
photograph in the movie because I mean
that is seared in my brain for the rest
of my life it made a big impression on
the story so if that's something that
you are just like nailing the perfect
frame or is that something that just
happened within the scene yeah well it
was kind of twofold I knew that that
image would become their legacy and I
knew that it will be plastered
everywhere because that's how I was
written I knew the importance of it and
so she had written it in a slightly
different way but I yeah I wanted it to
be a very specific composition I really
represent our queen and slims
right and their love for each other and
these amazing new people they become by
this point in the film and for the still
shot that jr. takes I wanted to bring in
another photographer who I really
admired and that's Andre Wagner
he shoots this beautiful black and white
film on film and so he came down to
shoot and he shoots in this really docu
style kind of in a way like a Gordon
Parks or a roy decarava
has done in the past and hid it he's
incredibly talented so we shot the scene
and then he reshot what junior took in
the in the in the scene and we've been
using that for the end of the film and
also on t-shirts and it became our
billboard it's a marketing campaign
kareem right there thank you so much
thank you